[Music]
this is Startalk
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and this is a
special installment of star talk in
support of live med aid why because they
exist in support of Doctors Without
Borders Chuck hey well you know about
doctors without borders on a terrific
organization they are been around for 50
years helping out the entire globe and
how cool is it for live med aid to
actually support them it's wonderful
yeah excellent
yeah excellent so Neil I'm sure a lot of
people are interested in your
perspective on the pandemic and one of
the things you've often talked about
throughout your entire career scientific
literacy so how do you think that
relates to what we're going through now
yeah I mean so of course I don't have
specific expertise in anything medical
alright so most if not all of what I
know I've learned from medical
professionals about the viruses about
the kovat 19 becoming a pandemic but
what I can tell you is there comes a
time when really the public needs to
listen to scientists in this case to
medical professionals and all the world
is not a debate about how you feel about
things all right I recently tweeted wit
has now become one of my top five ever
tweets ever ever been tweeting for 12
years ever it was a simple tweet and it
just said every I said you'd know it's
true every disaster movie begins with
people ignoring scientists absolutely so
and that seemed to resonate it hit a
chord with people got heavily retweeted
heavily liked or loved with the heart
sign and so people know that we're in
the middle of a there's tragedy that has
in part because people heard not only
people the public but people in power of
legislation and policy were had the ear
of scientists and elected not to take
the warnings seriously and so you have
something that could have been contained
within a it's a very contagious thing a
virus particularly one of this kind
which has a long incubation period where
you don't even know if you have the
virus and you end up spreading it to
others that's the that's a particularly
virulent version of a virus because I
think the very word variant comes from
virus itself so yeah so this is like
it's it's almost it's more than a shot
across our bow it shots directly at us
for how are we going to react when a
scientist says look what we've
discovered if you continue in this way
things will get worse you should put in
this protection you should make this
policy you should make these changes and
people don't like to change people don't
and if you just think a scientist is
just some crazy person that you have the
option to ignore then that has
consequences and we're in the middle of
this climate change
I can almost call that a climate change
pandemics it's a it's their scientist
climate scientist warning about what
effect our current actions will have on
the future of the climate and how that
affects the ecosystem and sea levels and
and immigration patterns you don't
become an immigrant you become what
happens if you were displaced because of
war or some other you know refugee it
definitely refugees seeking refuge is
yes you are a refugee and you know who
is paying attention to the scientists
the military and insurance companies yes
these people these people have very
direct vested interest in sort of
sensible positive outcomes
to to the warnings that that they
confront so this this Cove advice which
is the death toll is rising
it may be leveling off around now we're
recording this at just the beginning of
May 2020 but all I can say is we need to
see it as a lesson for how to listen to
scientists and whatever are the
consequences to you for having listened
to the experts and if those consequences
are things you don't like they're to be
compared with what the consequences
would have been from inaction that's
that's where the problem is because
that's where the problem is the
disconnect for people and we've already
seen it with the vet with the pandemic
they say well it's not that bad because
this didn't happen it's like no this
didn't happen because you did the thing
that stopped them from happening exactly
and there's a it's that famous quote why
don't you use to Andrew sampoo you don't
have danger
right yeah it's but what you say is very
powerful very poignant and the fact is
that people aren't people aren't
listening and for whatever reason I
don't understand it but they politicize
instead of acknowledging the science
yeah I think I understand a little bit
of it because in school when we're
taught a subject you're handed a pile of
knowledge right here's a book learn it
here are the key words you get the test
at the end of the segment and then they
grade you on what you remembered and as
they say regurgitated back science is
taught in the same way as any other
subject here's knowledge learn it
regurgitate it back but science is a
fundamentally different Enterprise from
everything else humans do science is a
way of querying Nate
it is a pathway from where you are to
objective truths about the natural world
and when you realize that you then
recognize that you don't have the option
to say I choose not to believe this
science because it conflicts with my
politics my culture my religion and as
I've said many times the good thing
about the interesting thing about
science is that it's true whether or not
you believe in it right that's an
important distinction and of course the
fleshed-out version of that I'm talking
about objective truths established by
repeated experiment that's the
scientific method so maybe had we been
taught science differently we would
treat the warnings of scientists
differently and I just waved them
against other things we wish were true
on the belief that it's just some other
information that we can take or leave
all right so my last question to you
Neil is is there any hopeful take away
from this collective tragedy silver
lining I think so I think so
the the preparedness of our agencies the
health care system the the World Health
Organization the and more domestically
the the Center for Disease Control
preparedness not only in the capacity to
receive patients who because with you
know they measure your ability to handle
disaster by how many beds per capita in
your population do you have and you said
well we're healthy we don't need that
many beds per guys we're never sick okay
but what happens if there's a tragedy or
if there's an emergency and now you have
people on cots in hallways spilling out
into the street just look at pandemic of
images from night the 1918 virus and you
go back into you see woodcuts of the the
bubonic plague where the bodies are just
getting carted out these are these are
tragedies that occur at
times when the system is incapable of
accommodating the actual assault that
was felt on the on the population so it
might mean rethinking what the emergency
backup support system to that would be
also what else would it take I worry
that the lessons learned today we'll
just get forgotten by a next generation
who may reward after it or or I worry
about that we need a better way to keep
information current about how we
confronted tackled and solved problems
that have happened before otherwise we
do him to repeat the mistakes Wow so
that is well let's just hope that
happens I'm gonna tell you well no I'm
I'm I'm just gonna shut up because I'm
not going to be positive well I know you
don't want to be positive be positive
but everything you said is measured
reasonable and it should happen that's
everything you said is measured and
reasonable and that is exactly what
should happen that we should now have
fail-safes and redundancies and
preparedness and all that but I you know
I don't I don't know if that's gonna
happen I'll just say okay I Chuck I'm a
little more hopeful in humanity than you
yeah all right yes let's say that one
other thing is that emergencies such as
this or disasters such as this have a
way of permanently changing some aspects
of people's conduct for example if you
go to Europe I guess France is it are
you still gonna get that toupees screen
now that there's some inflation I've
seen some places where they get a three
kids I think is that really still gonna
happen everybody think everybody's gonna
be kid and play from now on it's gonna
be a tote at the toe the feet the kid
played those who are for 40 and older it
will remember kidding this is a group I
think from the 80s they have a really
fun video where they just you tap
yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah so
there's some things that could
permanently change as a result of this
you know how much hand sanitizer you
keep it around the house which is how
many how many times you sanitize
surfaces just in general because all
viruses will transmit the same way and
every year here viruses it could be
here's a silver lining it could be that
the next cold and flu season totally
smashed down uh because our habits are
so thorough right that that wintertime
flu didn't have a chance with the flu
Chuck another silver lining here it may
be that you know in the old days that
always be someone at the office sneezing
tissue sniffling now they've all get it
talking to ya the people gonna be
looking at them so get your ass home
right okay no long hopen no longer are
you the little warrior like I came to
work sick because I'm such a good
employee now it's not like it it gets
you that's right good babies home and
now you we know for many jobs you can
still do it at home with the right
setups so I think those are some of the
silver linings right wait up
well let's hope the one of the best
sober linings will be that I'll be able
to get a table at laverna den when this
is over fancy restaurant in New York
City it is I can't wait Chuck Chuck do
we do we pay you that much that you may
eat nibla burden ha ha no but they're
gonna need a business I know so with
that what do you what are your kind of
overarching final thoughts on this whole
thing
you know I tend to bring a cosmic
perspective to what I do they let me
think of it as a cosmic lens through
which I see the world and I see this
virus yeah it's it's a virus yeah
yeah it's got RNA and it knows how to
get inside your DNA I get that but you
know what it really is to me it's an
invader from space okay it's not
actually it's not actually from space
but imagine if we did have an invader
from space that threatened all of
humanity we would need a way for all of
us to get together put down your swords
put down your against each other
put down your differences because in
this moment we are all the same the
tribalism that separates us if we can't
ever get rid of it let's say at least
but let's at least combine that
tribalism to turn all of humans into one
tribe to fight the one of the one enemy
and so so for me this is a practice run
if the day ever comes where hostile
aliens come to try to take over Earth
what are we gonna do how are we gonna do
it will we cooperate with each other and
give a unified front so that none of us
are taken out by this foreign enemy so
that's how I think about this and I
think others should think about it that
way as well and that could be the source
of what brings us all together in peace
and harmony forever going forward it's a
common enemy to or that the enemy of my
friend is my enemy
so yeah that's real that'd be great if
what you just said happened and I'm just
gonna shut up now and just bask in that
because you know that's a beautiful
thing right right and I think also
there's gotta be a version of that
because if I'm fighting someone else and
they're my enemy now there's an enemy to
us both so my enemy becomes my friend
and we can both fight the common enemy
to us both
right that's that's that's the thinking
that would have to unfold here
absolutely but that's that for me that's
my cosmic perspective on this that's
very cool
that's very cool and could a virus
survive in space some do oh yeah okay
that is not the answer I was looking for
thank you but it'll survive better in
your lungs all right well we certainly
want to thank everyone who was out there
and all the efforts from the medical
community and you can support their
efforts through supporting live med aid
and we hope you do and to everyone be
safe stay healthy take care of others
and as always keep looking up
[Applause]
you